this man has changed you know like
thousands of people's lives so every
[Music]
Valley so you can say for a week that's
it it looks like a stay high in a season
trash the property accepts if I pay cash
for it right now how much here except
for it we need to go to the London
mathematics says you're a piece of my
name is Glen Kirkham I'm 34 I live in
Blackpool I'm a father of three this is
a great look for you thanks
[Music]
so obviously I did in this documentary
to do a social experiment where I will
move to one of the poorest towns in the
UK go and live in someone's house who
has nothing no money at all and see if I
can teach them my knowledge and my
skills and see if I can make a poor
person become rich in one week let's see
what happens
[Music]
oh yeah
is it because I'm something there is
absolutely no privacy in this room
whatsoever because I know where this is
going man you know yeah I'll let your
trepidation with that's his deal this is
so out of the ordinary look at this I
know rebuttal now I just got a feeling
that I'm a seagull on my car night this
isn't good
[Music]
[Music]